[Music]
everybody thank you for hanging out with
us here at Daly Danny live on Danny
direct oh I'm selfish lazy and believe
it or not we are just two days away now
from the Royal Wedding
we're excited I know you guys are too in
just a few we are gonna show you how to
throw the most regal viewing party for
the Royal Wedding and for a lot of us is
gonna be really early but don't worry
booze is involved but first we're
tossing it back over to Lauren's Ian who
is on the ground in London
Lauren we're here to talk to you about
the power of hair Meghan markle's hair
has really taken off her messy buns her
blowouts and you were incredibly
influential obviously still are but from
the start with Diana's hair I met her
through Vogue magazine there was a photo
shoot being shot by Patrick Demarchelier
and Vogue and Patrick introduced me to
Diana in 1990 and we did a very famous
shot of her now where she's sitting on
the floor in a white satin dress and she
sat on the floor when she was getting
dressed ready to go to go home she said
well what would you do with my hair if I
gave you complete carte blanche I just
cut it all off and start again and said
okay let's do it now and the next day
the world's press went absolutely
bananas and I was absolutely astounded
it was quite incredible in retrospect it
was a very significant time for her and
I guess people change their hair a lot
when they're going through certain times
in their life growing up it became
iconic and now Megan Markel is very
quickly becoming known for Oh an iconic
messy bun why is hair something that
people do focus on so much you're seeing
people say how can I get Megan Markel's
messy bun why does it connect people so
much well I think people can relate to
hair people might not be able to afford
that dress or those shoes but they
certainly can afford a haircut or a
product or they could do the hair
themselves it's a it's it's Tayna belitz
approachable you can project the image
that you would like to project starting
with your hair there's an ease to her
you know she's experienced
as much as she's not a naive to the
person who has never experienced the
power of the media for she's media savvy
and I think she's doing a great job
McKnight says he misses Diana in the way
she'd light up any room
he says the princess's hair in part
became iconic by accident what Diana
wanted her hair to be was both
functional and respectful she wouldn't
go all out with clothes or hair because
she knew the attention would be focused
on something other than was the focus of
the day interesting clever she was
mindful about that he was very mindful
about her her her whole world was her
children our charities I used to say to
us sometimes look you don't need you
don't need to have your hair done today
all this because your hell it's really
great naturally to come out the gym they
should but the thing is when I go to
open an old people's home or a
children's school they don't see this
woman who's come out the gym they want
to see Princess Diana so I have to
respect that and I completely understood
that so as you said hair can be
attainable so that's something that we
love is that we can try to get the look
of the Royals and you're working on a
new product time I am we're working on
quite an extensive product line in what
we've just started with for texturizing
sprays and hairspray and a dry shampoo
which actually are instant fixers
instant transformers that dull dry
products they're very easy to use
they're very modern they get results
really quickly thanks Lauren
we've been keeping a real busy over
there clearly awful while Lauren's hard
at work we're about to have some fun you
guys joining us now is fellow ET host
Holly Stevens who's here to help us plan
the ideal and regal royal wedding
dealing party oh yeah right yeah and you
got to start with a dress code right
that's true so I came bearing gifts
it is an early night encourage your
guests to come in their PJs you you're
gonna wrap Markel okay Jack and you
comfy it's so early a tear is like
practically in the middle of the night
it's gonna be tough
well throw on the west coast it's like
what four in the morning morning I mean
like afraid that's gonna be tough so you
want your guests to be comfortable
always so tell them to come in their
pajamas the extra festive obviously a
onesie is always highly encouraged but
it is a wedding so we kind of want to be
fancy too so I encourage you to channel
your inner Prince Harry with a top hat
oh my god you know princesses Beatrice
and Eugenie from 2011 who could forget
that classmate or moment just tight
squeeze but I'm doing this was fitted
for Miss Marco do you guys see the
spread behind us let's go talk about it
okay so it's not a party without booze
let's be real in the morning so we don't
want to be too aggressive we have dubbed
this the Marco sparkle I love it yeah
cute it's just a twist on your mimosa I
thought you were leaving because you're
pregnant
juice yeah sans alcohol maybe yes you
know so what is this so this is blood
orange juice with just a splash like an
ounce or so and then yes take a sip tell
me what you think you know it's on theme
oh yeah that is good
can I smell it yeah yeah yeah please and
I think you said earlier it's red like
Harry's hair ginger the ginger drink you
guys also perfect for the morning and
then next we have lemon elderflower
cupcakes this is actually the cake that
the Kensington Palace announced that
Meghan and Harry would be serving at the
reception
super super yummy one of our co-workers
made this recently and we all died for
it it was amazing you can have one that
I didn't definitely tell you these smell
so good
smellivision
for you I don't have a sweet tooth so
but I'm gonna have that oh yeah does it
taste like wedding cake sure it tastes
very decadent very regal very um what is
this frosting it's like a vanilla
vanilla bean yeah yeah yes so and
there's elderflower in the cup and
there's like a little surprise in there
oh you know they know to be like a royal
look and then over here we have what
we're calling the Union Jack berry
parfait so we kind of wanted to channel
the British flag a little bit with red
white and blue it's so easy it's just
berries yogurt honey granola and a
little mint to make it look extra regal
so cute it's all about the presentation
it really is you know oh thanks you know
we're calling it Harry's royalty mmm
miracle Harry we got the whole thing
going and it's my fav brunch item you
know yes and then it's not a tea party
without some tea sandwiches so this
really you can let your imagination go
wild if you like grilled cheese
sandwiches just make a mini these are
veggie but that's America honestly like
jelly
ham and cheese as long as they are
petits mudal set them out make them look
pretty and that's all you got to do and
then we have some scones you can pick
these up at the bakery you don't even
have to make them this is like yes get
it done they're so easy and to make sure
that your guests feel like a queen like
they're eating at a regal stable setting
we have red white and blue tables red
flowers really just kind of use your
imagination you can put the flag out
anything you want just make it regal I'm
never going to be invited to a Queen's
table so we're actually going to link
out all of these recipes on ET online so
if you didn't get a chance to grab it
it'll be there for you waiting well
alright so we've eaten the drinks are
still flowing oh yeah
rasca we do that morning of the Royal
Wedding okay so to keep everybody
entertained and kind of engaged and
having a little fun because it is kind
of a long procession we have hooked you
guys up with et's royal wedding bingo
yeah we've got funny things in there
like you know Spice Girls or Elton John
suits co-stars mention that wedding Mel
B oh yeah I love this talk about who was
not invited oh snap shade I know and you
guys we told you our sources tell us the
Spice Girls have been invited so that's
at least two squares right there I'm
just saying how fun how cute your guests
will have a blast it'll be so much fun
and you guys were actually gonna link a
download link to the bingo cards and the
what do you call these markers Megan
markers markers we're gonna leave that
to you guys in the description so you
guys can play at home all I have to do
is print it I love that easy enough yeah
and it's not a you know party without a
photobooth gotta have a regal photo
booth so obviously what you want your
dress like this gotta be right on theme
out of document you Megan mark oh thank
you no how about we make you Harry okay
and I'm gonna be the queen you can get
regal with like a tiara yeah you know
it's super easy and all you need are
these Union Jack flag really right this
will wait what Harry is actually wearing
friend snap a pic we look so fun fun at
home with this stuff too awesome thank
you so much Holly you're actually good
for feeding us forgiveness this drink
really drinking on Saturday morning for
sure are you guys that's it for today
thank you so much for watching I hope
you guys had a blast watching this one
we'll be back tomorrow
12 p.m. Pacific for the last o daily
deni live before the royal wedding on
Saturday morning I can't believe it's
actually happy sorry guys for watching
we'll see you tomorrow take some pics
where you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]